wird die la famiglia leiden schmeiß es
in den trichter ja ja
kallinchen meine lieben freunde und
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge von
minecraft leben hier auf dem
wundervollen server gerade ist hier
selbstverständlich nacht und die
handwerks gilt es steht auch bisher nur
noch zum teil also bisher nur zum teil
nicht nur noch weil sie wird natürlich
noch aufgebaut die inneneinrichtung
eines hauses lässt auch noch zu wünschen
übrig aber ewig schon ich habe das ein
kleines geteiltes sofa hingestellt und
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich mache
heute wieder meine folge alleine einfach
so ein bisschen chillig ein bisschen rum
schauen und so und ich werde auf jeden
fall jetzt einfach mal bitte kann man
neuerdings über minecraft reden ich
wollte nicht allein was ist in ihrem set
wurde scheinbar implementiert in game
voice chat das ist ja unglaublich
das ist völlig verrückt hermann weiß
aber natürlich nicht wahr nicht wagen
hilft natürlich
hallo wie geht's denn mit mir sehr gut
getan
hier nehmen weiß nicht ich komme ich
eigentlich rein
doch es gab nicht gesichert ist nicht
gesichert an jeder ecke leute herzlich
willkommen wir nichts zu verstecken hier
bei den eltern und freunde ihr kommt mit
meinen heiligen halb europa jugendtag
und wir haben ja
wir haben gestern oder irgendwann in
letzter zeit ich weiß nicht wann genau
diese folge online kommt schon etwas
verkündet und zwar alle sagt dem
zuschauer noch mal was wir beschlossen
haben
wir haben zwischen den edgar iana den
glorreichen etwa iranern und natürlich
der fast noch glorreichen handwerks
gilde ein bündnis geschlossen
denn in letzter zeit macht ja die la
famiglia jagd auf menschen zum beispiel
auch schweine und das können wir nicht
zulassen das können wir nicht zulassen
und deshalb haben wir uns verbündet um
gegen so ein verhalten vorzugehen
herr genau meine lieben freunde habt ja
in der letzten folge bei mir und auch
schon bei sturm war vorgesehen bei sturm
waffe wurde über alle hingesetzt dinge
abgebaut dinge geklaut bei mir wurde ich
wurde angegriffen von den leuten ich
wurde belästigt sie sind auf meinem
grundstück herum geträumt und da möchten
wir jetzt einfach mit dieser verbindung
quasi einfach so dagegen wirkt nur
deswegen haben wir uns gedacht der
piloten ist auf jeden fall mit seiner
karriere ein würdevoller partner ein
verbündeter von der handwerkskammer
schon da reitet er auf seinem kleinen
richtung prozent er steht eigentlich
hobbit steht eigentlich einfach nur rum
und der valuten möchte mehr zeit heute
in dieser folge einmal ganz kurz zeigen
ein häuslein vielleicht auch was genau
die aquarianer sind vielleicht kennt ihr
ja gar nicht die kleinen diensten
schweiz
und ja die kommen übrigens aus der zeit
vom 1 das galaxy noch oder ja die edgar
wurde in der zeit von minecraft galaxy
geboren etwa der erste da gab es
natürlich ganz mitkommen
da sehen wir wie gesagt die la famiglia
hatte eben ein attentat auf die edgar
iana verübt hier liegt der fünfte der
wurde hingerichtet
das gute allerdings an egger ist
und auch an der heutigen technologie das
natürlich mittlerweile ist möglich ist
etwa zu klonen dazu können wir hier kurz
in den stall reingehen maler weise war
es ja auch geplant hier vorne siehst du
auch noch ein schwein das willy willy
ist eigentlich dafür da gewesen dass
edgar ist sozusagen das land opel
erwerben
der sollte eigentlich dann geopfert
werden es ist willi und hier vorne sehen
wir die die clown maschine die ist auch
ein entschuldigen sie bisher nichts
anfassen entschuldigung bitten nichts
anfassen die die maschine ist auch
gerade noch beim ecklohn von edgar
beschäftigt mit dem sex und dann
mittlerweile unterhält
unser ja unser gemüse was ich nicht so
ganz verstehe ja doch willi das dann du
willst wieso wird denn dann wirklich
edgar getötet ja das problem ist ich hab
nach familie in mein haus gelassen weil
ich dachte man könnte den vertrauen und
anwohner hätten einfach von ratten
angezogen lacht ist man könnte der la
familia vertrauen und es war ein
trugschluss ich bin ja das problem ist
die edw ariana sind prinzipiell den
leuten natürlich offen gestimmt und wir
sind positive menschen und glaub ich ist
übrigens die heilige charakter genauso
wie die handwerks gilde
aber wenn man wenn man mit angriff
rechnen muss dann bleibt einem keine
andere wahl paletten definitiv und dann
wegen zurückgeschlagen es mir ja nicht
zurückgeschlagen nakiska ka fall wird
zurückgeschlagen
ja das sind so kleine zeichen die die
niemand verstehen wird google video
gewusst die andere tür benutzen schnell
andere tür hatte extra zwei gemacht
falls etwas passiert gefällt weil du
wirst und es gibt natürlich auch die
ariane haben natürlich auch noch etwas
unterirdisches kommt kommt rein sind
okay dann gehen wir mal ganz kurz hin
denn edgar iana sind natürlich auch so
ein bisschen wie ich muss ja auch ein
bisschen geld verdienen
und dazu wird hier unten gerade eine
kleine arena gebaut das ist asozial
unterhält ich bin einfach halb tot
hier wird momentan noch gebaut und ihr
vorne sehen schon eine riesige statue
des heiligen etwas mit seiner heiligen
krone
okay jetzt kann ich ja hier wird wieder
eifrig gebaut hier oben ist eine kleine
vip-lounge da gibt es kostenlos
zuckerrohr
ja ja hier sind wir gerade als ok also
ich meine dass die die hand wechselt ist
auch gerne dazu eingeladen hier mal in
der arena wenn sie dann fertig gestellt
wird den ein oder anderen kampf auf
leben und tod auszutragen die wird es
dann weg gegeben dass man eben auf einen
von den beiden kämpfern wetten kann hier
vorne wird ebenfalls noch ein eingang
gebaut es ist momentan alles noch ein
bisschen in arbeit das sieht man aber
schon schon schon menschliche hirn ist
noch hermann hermann der zombie und ok
ok ludo meinte tulu denn dora die sind
die sind allerdings keine ahnung ich hab
die irgendwo aus dem katalog bestellt
zum bauen und sie sind einfach die sind
sehr produktiv oder klappte gut gerade
vielleicht ich weiß nicht ob die
handwerks gilt es ein paar leute hat
jeder sein die handwerks gilde wird dir
da auf jeden fall entgegen kommen denn
wie es schon wisst bluten ist nun
einfach verbündeter der handwerker bzw
die edgar iana sind komplett verbündet
mit uns das heißt wir werden natürlich
auch genau erst mal hier um
so falsch wie wir werden da noch so ab
und zusammen paar treffen veranstalten
auch mal zu dritt aufnehmen die edgar
jahner die handwerks gilt eventuelle
bekommt die handwerkskammer noch mehr
zuwachs wer weiß wer weiß meine lieben
freunde und dann wird er die ein oder
andere sache geplant
sage ich mal natürlich ist es gibt ja
übrigens auch falls ihr es noch nicht
mal hier
die komische amino amelio leute hier
haben riesige unterirdische
getreidespeicher alter und das mündet
direkt bei dir ein
ja ja das ist es auch unter den gebäuden
und das kranke ist ja hab ich mal nach
unten wie nach unten
wir können kannst es dir einfach ist
noch mal flecken fällt alles ist noch da
unten
wie viel essen haben die denn ich weiss
es nicht ist völlig krank darf man sich
wohl einfach mal was mitnehmen wenn man
das wieder an bord klar okay krass dann
dann würde ich hier trieben das ist es
diese in sachen alter das ist doch
unglaublich dürfen die das überhaupt ich
weiß es nicht das ist doch riesig die
sind doch direkt unter dem grundstück
eigentlich ihr eigenheim
ein verstoß gegen die regeln ja aber ich
glaube das ist etwa das interesse oder
so der das alles hier errichtet das
schon ein bisschen bisschen können wir
hier
und die sind ganz viele sahen eine sowie
essen was ist denn
halt eher was ist denn los da ist ja so
viel weizen trainiert sogar alles mit
raps und die kommen wahrscheinlich
einfach einmal hier den schalter drücken
oder bluten quasi zum schalter
wahrscheinlich wird dann einfach wasser
einmal drüber gekippt dennoch fragen
einfach alles einmal nach pflanze aber
ich lass das jetzt mal die bonbon
absagen und pflanzen könnten bisschen
dauern lieber nicht älter aber was haben
wir denn jetzt hier gefunden
krass ey na ja er wolle nur einfach die
treppe hoch nehmen oder wo es gerade wer
ich bin ich bin auch glaube ich hoch
gelaufen die die ihre lieben ein
abenteuer
ja ich weiß gar nicht genau wo wir sind
bist du sicher dass wir hier raus und
yamaha wir sind in der kirche hier gibt
es auch dass das freilich ganz cool wenn
man mit hier direkt auf der
gegenüberliegenden seite dass es
scheinbar irgendwie das orakel wäre -
aber das ändert alles echt so krasser
illuminati so alles so unterhöhlt und
der kirche und dann sind das so
geheimnisvolle sachen bekannt zu amino
was fragen amino was fragen amino
prophezeit die einem jahr am ende
prophezeit die ein nein
ok soll ich mal was fragen wer macht die
frage ich denn was einfach was auf das
papier zu schreiben
ja wird die handwerks gilde erfolgreich
agieren passt da nicht hin
die amino kirche weiß ja was gemein
erfolgreich aktiv werden wir das spiel
einfach wird die handwerks gilde erfolg
aber okay das ist jetzt im trichter wie
war ja ehrlich mehr ernst
da kommen rosige zeiten auf uns zu
ok möchte dass frank ok uns erst auf den
amboss wenn man etwas andere frage wird
die la famiglia irgendwie sowas dass wir
damals schon mal eine antwort wissen
la familia leiden wird die la famiglia
leiden meistens in den trichter
den segen der - auf jeden fall das heißt
die harmlos sind auf jeden fall da auf
unserer seite und ich meine ganz ehrlich
die la famiglia was die hier abziehen
wir sind einfach mega viele monster oder
die la famiglia was nicht einfach
abziehen
ich meine man hätte alles in frieden
lösen können aber wenn ich dann in
frieden auf meinem grundstück stehe und
dann einfach schon angegriffen werden
das ist für mich halt einfach auch schon
vorbei ja ich meine es hätte auch ein
kopfschuss sein können oder besser weg
gemeinschaft macht das auch einen
riesigen unterschied sei deswegen punkt
dass man wenn ihr auf einem kleinen
zehnagel schießt dann tötet er auch so
ein bisschen in der 18
natürlich hast du ein bisschen
angeschwollen und so wie sie hier was zu
essen für mich natürlich durch natürlich
ganz viel mitgenommen
ich war so lange fahne und das einzige
was gefunden waren 13 reisen
das ist er aber du musst echt diese
diese luftblasen diesen beschlüssen die
luft blasen das werde ich mir auf jeden
fall merken ja herr paletten dann würde
ich die die verbindung die wir hier mit
eingeschlossen haben muss ja auch
irgendwie festgehalten werden dass
weiterhin letzte was ich sagen würde was
für diese folge noch auf jeden fall
getan werden muss wir müssen am besten
sondern ein kleines büchlein beschreiben
wo drinsteht dass das ganze jetzt
wirklich stattgefunden hat er hasst du
tnt tnt
ich habe aber nicht mobil ist
aufschreiben können
ich habe auch keine angst oder irgendwie
sowas denn die heilige schrift der edgar
iana aber die kann ich jetzt nicht dafür
opfern dass das ganze wirklich nicht das
heute nicht das möchte ich nicht zumuten
dann werde ich auf jeden fall erstmal
die handwerks gilde kannst du gerne
mitkommen du möchtest du gegen eine
sekunde ich glaube ich hab hier unten
noch das wäre super wenn man einfach ein
kleines büchlein schreiben könnte dass
es jetzt wirklich fest auf dem tisch ist
dass wir verbündete sind bei sonst ich
würde auf jeden fall dann erst mal ein
kleines schildchen bei mir an bringen in
der handwerks gilde dass wir verbündete
mit den edgar jahnern sind
ich hab' ich hab leider leider ist
dieses buch will das ist schon das wurde
kompliziert rüdiger wollte hierfür passt
vielleicht werden wir es ruhiger
rüdiger schwein ihr das nicht etwa ist
gerade der maschine
das war gestern der maschine und musst
vorsichtig kassen der maschine
und wer denkt er ist noch in der
schießstand dinge schwein genau wie
gesagt wird dennoch eine maschine ist es
unser erlöser und ich komme ja nicht
irgendwer über christiane seitz vorbei
kein problem mal eben schnell zur
handwerks gilt übrigens der eingang sun
fun facts gilde ist natürlich eigentlich
hier
er wird noch schöner gestaltet wird
alles schöner gestaltet aber wir stellen
jetzt erst mal provisorisch hier drauf
manchmal ebenso verbündet
doch je erhöhen und dann werden auf
jeden fall noch mehr verbündete dazu
kommen dass man nicht freunde die
handwerks gilde ist ja nicht negativ wir
sind ja einfach eine friedliche
handwerks gilde wo man falls sie den
sind nicht so ganz verstanden habt ihn
ist folge von sturm waffe weil das ein
bisschen chaotisch war es wird eine
handwerkerin sein ich hatte ja auch
schon so ein büchlein gefunden wo mir
ein user auf dem server gefragt hat ja
möchtest du vielleicht ein bisschen
cobblestone haben den ich gemeine und so
sowas wird einfach über die
handwerkskammer geregelt allerdings
weekends natürlich wenn die handwerks
gilt attackiert wird dann sind wir keine
gilde die dann auch sagt nur das lasse
über uns und lassen uns gefallen
das heißt da muss man dann auf jeden
fall auch partei ergreifen und schauen
wie es das ganz einfach entwickeln da
wird uns der piloten auf jeden fall bei
stehen das heißt mehrere folgen wären
jetzt in zukunft mit palmen und stürmer
von auch zusammen sein und dann werden
wir mal sehen wie sich das ganze in
zukunft noch entwickelt hast du noch
irgendwelche abschieden den worten ich
freue mich auf die glorreiche zukunft
zwischen den edgar iranern und der
handwerks gilde und ich denke wir werden
das auf jeden fall gut gedeckelt
bekommen und ich freue mich auf die
zukunft wann ich schreib doch ein und
wird rosig ein wichtiger schritt dahin
bin gespannt
wir haben den segen der - das ist echt
witzig als sie einfach beide male ja
gesagt hat wir werden erfolgreich und ja
es wird auch gegen die gladbacher ja ich
sag das ding immer ja das kann man nicht
vergessen dass wir traurig
okay aber nun gut ich meine unsere ziele
waren uns alles fragen sie einfach etwas
negativer ist einfach immer nur sachen
wo wenn ja ja und dann kommt man ja bei
raus
deswegen meine lieben freunde das war's
für diese voll gemeinschaft leben
zusammen mit dem piloten
ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen in ok
besser sein verhalten dulden wir endlich
nicht mehr handwerks gelder okay aber
jetzt stress in einer anderen folge
wieder wo dann wahrscheinlich dieses
gebäude zu haben wie aufgeregt ich
brauche die zusammenarbeit und demnächst
wird das dann auch so sein dass die
handwerks gilde noch ausgebaut wird und
so freut euch darauf interessante sachen
und dann sehen wir uns in einer anderen
folge wieder werden bei palud noch etwas
aufgenommen wo ich das nochmal genau
erklärt habe und so da könnt ihr auch
gerne vorbeischauen oben in der
beschreibung verlinkt und dann würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freunde wir
sehen uns in einem anderen video wieder